[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
reggie aloysius miller jr iii the hall
of famer he'll be on the call thursday
night lakers and the warriors and reggie
is back on the program hi reg how are
you today hello theodore and my lovely
danettes how cool though would it be
and again another
cinderella come from behind comeback
story
if tiger says you know what
in the 11th hour okay i'll play and then
goes out and just stampedes you know the
course and the competition i mean how
awesome would that be
it's just amazing if he plays
i mean that that alone is
you know monumental
but now it feels like
he's playing we expect him to do well
not it went from maybe he can play
around one round now it's now he's going
to play he's going to make the cut he'll
be there on sunday afternoon like that
we ratchet up our expectations with
tiger more so than probably any other
athlete
and i think
if you ask tiger he would probably want
it that way right
i mean he's been in the public eye over
20 years
uh obviously chasing jack in
in grand slams i think he would wanted
no other way and
we expect
greatness from our you know mount
olympus type athletes and tiger is on
mount olympus in terms of
in today's age
first name basis
worldwide appeal
tiger woods may be the face of all of
sports so yeah we we would expect that
but did i hear this right
in his words was an amputation on the
table
for that leg yeah
yeah i think yeah i think it was well
he nearly lost his life
then he nearly lost his leg
and that's 14 months ago and now
now i look at what alex smith went
through with all of those surgeries he
was going to lose his leg he was
quarterbacking the nfl like nobody's
chasing tiger you know he gets to walk
but you know what alex smith did was
remarkable as well have you ever met
tiger
yes
yes nice fella
yes yes i've met him a few times but
you're not a golfer so what what did you
talk about
um
it's funny
i met him in vegas which
this is
this is before kids for me before the
whole scandal with him
so it's only fitting that i would meet
him in vegas
i was coming in i was going out of a
club he was coming into the club
and we crossed paths and exchanged
pleasantries who's more vegas you or
tiger
now no the old no no the old the old you
i i we probably could give each other a
run for our money
wow
but are you a gambler
a little bit i'm not on the charles
barkley level but i like to roulette
blackjack
i like to hold on to my money and i know
vegas was built on dummies like me so i
don't want to give them too much of it
but it's fun just to kind of have fun
with your with your you know with your
boys sometimes can do you think
in the next five years we have an nba
team in vegas yes
i think we'll have two nba teams and i'm
hoping this vegas and seattle needs to
get a franchise as well i think we will
have two within the next
five years i i do believe that how
dangerous do you think that will be
everything is online betting now
i think people are over it i mean
fanduel and all these other
spots
mgm
that's the way of the world now so i i
i know the league's hesitation we've got
an nfl team there
no i meant i'm at the nightlife reg not
the gambling i mean you you're going to
have night life you have nightlife in
indiana you have nightlife in milwaukee
you can have nightlife in cleveland okay
the least dangerous city at night
as far as partying
was where
while i played
yeah
i don't
know you're not going to get in too much
trouble in milwaukee
you're not going to get in too much
trouble in utah
charles got in trouble everywhere didn't
he yeah yeah
yeah i mean
it's how it you can create your own
trouble i remember going to the
underground in salt lake city
i don't know what the underground is
really it was a speakeasy we walked down
an alley
and you knocked on this door
what
and this was during uh the utah jazz
chicago bulls nba finals
i speak easy in utah
rodman was in there
i walk in because rodman always thought
i was craig sager
he would always say i walk in the place
is packed
packed you would never know that it
existed i walk in and all of a sudden
uh rodman's there and he goes hey segger
sager and i i go oh he thinks i'm craig
sager i said hey dennis how are you the
only thing you can say
are closely resembled is maybe your
height i think you guys are probably the
same height other than that that's
it you ever been out with rodman
yes plenty of times
like out out like yes plenty of times in
l.a plenty of times and and what goes on
any and everything
everything is on the table with him
i'm more reserved and cautious because i
always like to know my surroundings like
who i'm dealing with so
he he was not like that he would just
have random people come up and that's
just not me
so though i was a part of his i guess
entourage and posse i kind of stayed to
myself because i'm more of a watcher
looker observer when i'm in these
situations because
you just never know what could pop off
what could happen
so seeing him
and this is dennis rodman the whole
after the madonna the champion it's it's
it's surreal to see because i've been
out with him hanging
obviously i've hung out with mike
in situations like that and it's
you see the different type of people
that gravitate towards them
and it's kind of it's cool to see but
like it kind of sucks too like
you know i i feel i have a name
recognition but people don't like flaunt
to me
they flaunt to mj they flaunted to magic
johnson they flaunt to rodman i guess
they would want to lebron kobe
but kobe never went out um but it's just
weird to see the different type of
people that kind of
serenade them
you mentioned lebron magic johnson was
on espn yesterday and he blamed lebron
for the lakers not getting demar derozan
that they wanted to get demar derozan
who was available
and magic said he pushed for it but
lebron wanted russell westbrook does
that sound right
i think at the end of the day your best
player your star player and obviously in
lakers case that would be lebron they
had to have gone to lebron and asked him
here's the less the list of guys that
we're thinking about i do know on that
list was demar
i know on that list was buddy healed
i know on that list was kyle lowry
so they had options and choices
and look
if lebron feels comfortable playing with
russell and that's his choice
i have no problem with that i'm not
going to blame him because
but do you think it's lebron's decision
that if i think
but heavy input yes
heavy input i would say and that's been
lebron every place he's been
starting in cleveland going to miami
going back to cleveland and now l.a
absolutely you would go to lebron and
ask him his input on certain players i
mean how did they get
anthony davis you don't think lebron had
a heavy
dose of say yeah yeah and same agent too
right
but
you know the star players like magic
didn't make good decisions
in in the front office michael didn't
make good you know decisions in the
front office
you know that's remember michael wanted
to bring
uh
uh walter davis into the bulls when he
was on one league in one leg al wood he
you know and then jerry crown said no
didn't michael draft i'll just i mean i
love kwame brown
but and adam morrison
so i mean
look
great players sometimes are always their
worst critics because they think they
need they know more than they actually
do
but i am not going to criticize lebron
if he wanted to play with russell
westbrook
as opposed to demar derozan because
demar derozan the season that he's
having right now in chicago did we see
any of that in san antonio we saw
glimpses of it yeah but we didn't see
that full package that we're seeing in
chicago right now
yeah but russ is either really good or
really bad demar derozan is steady like
if it was an ekg you'd be like oh my god
that patient's going to die no he's
going to live to be a hunter demar
derozan's like
he's like joe dumars it's just like
calm no highlights just goes out there
and plays get you some buckets mid-range
jumpers
uh again i i can't fault lebron for
wanting to play with with russell and
i mean
here's the problem
they're throwing frank vogel underneath
underneath the bus which to me is not
fair i
who
should be skating on thin ice should be
rob polinka seriously
he's the general manager he's the
president whatever title he has with the
lakers i don't know why we always want
to
go to lebron it's lebron's fault it's
frank vogel's fault you got to start
looking at upper management you guys are
looking at the bus family genie bus too
right they're the ones that put this
roster together yeah you know rocker uh
lebron is out there is he recruiting
absolutely is he asking some of his
parents to play like carmelo absolutely
but they can at the end of the day say
no they could have went out and got
buddy healed they could have vetoed that
and said we're going to go with demar
derozan
so don't always throw lebron underneath
the bus let's start looking at some of
the principles here in genie bus and rob
palinka as well
but they could have had demar derozan
and buddy healed
they could have done i
and here's the thing you look at
lebron's skill set
and what he needs guys that can shoot to
three
that can make open shots like demar um
probably the best mid-range player in
our game
that fits his skill set so someone in
upper management needs to say okay i
know he wants to play with russell
westbrook but his skill set doesn't fit
the way we and lebron plays
so there's got to be a grown-up in the
room now yeah right so let's not always
throw it up on lebron james shoulders
and and you get to see the lakers on
thursday night on tnt again which could
be an elimination game for them right
this could be an elimination from the
playoff game for them
we want them in the play although
anthony davis says the world is against
us that i don't
i mean there's more laker fans
than any other fan base right
right and and and every tv executive who
carries the nba wants the lakers in
we do we have the west this year
let's make no mistake
having the lakers in the playoffs in a
deep playoff run that's huge for
the business of the nba right yeah not
even having them in the playoffs
at all is terrible for the business but
not i mean i would love to have them in
the play-in situation because those
games are and i give adam silver a lot
of credit
it adds a lot of juice now to the
playoffs yeah the lakers hopefully if
they got into that 10th spot having to
win in new orleans and then you know
eventually having to play the winner or
the loser of that i believe it's
minnesota clippers that adds juice so
yes not having them in the playoffs
would hurt
reggie miller hall of famer turner
sports nba and ncaa tournament analyst i
mentioned this last week it feels like
the tournament is either you're 18 years
of age or you're 23 or 24.
right yes right yeah you're i agree that
the transfer portal
i think to me
it injected something into college
basketball because of the whole kobe
situation it gave those guys
and players what an extra year fifth
year seniors
you know we were calling that
uh kansas versus miami
uh elite eight game in chicago
and between mitch lightfoot cameron
mcgusty uh remy martin i mean all these
guys are fifth and six yeah i believe
magusti was 24 years old i'm like
24. like they're playing against like 18
to 19 year olds i'm like that's a
clear-cut advantage so yeah i mean i get
it i like it
so
it adds a little juice to it but we're
going to get back to these kids coming
out of high school going right to the
nba right
i think so yeah or going straight to the
g league
whatever it is now uh to make some money
yeah i think eventually
the world will correct itself and
if someone wants to play
college for a year
which to me i wish they would or they
need to change this model around because
of the nils now and
players being able to make money
players may start to say you know what i
can go to college for a couple years
still work on my brand while making
money
and the colleges win as well because
you're getting
top 20 top 50 tight
players
still playing in the college game
did kansas win it or north carolina lose
it
i'm never going to take away anything
from the champions um
but if you're up 16 in the second half
of a college game where you can control
35 second shot clock and you've just got
to make plays
and squeeze the life out of that orange
that's a tough pill to swallow being up
16 and losing a championship but i'm
going to give all the credit to kansas
because when we were calling kansas in
chicago i told
harlan and dan bonner this
they did not look good at all they
played that one great second half versus
miami and blew them out in the second
half but the
the other
three quarters were just okay they
played hard they had great talent but i
just didn't see it so when they won that
miami game and was headed to new orleans
i'm like
you know that kid from villanova has
never heard
could this be a different
outcome for them because what we saw
from villanova when we had them in
pittsburgh i'm like this is the team to
beat their defense their ball movement
the way they shoot the basketball but 23
and 24 year olds they have like
gillespie and samuels and more i'm like
villanova's the team to beat but when
that kid got hurt i'm like kansas caught
a break right there
uh mvp this year is going to be
an mvp this year should be
those different answers
the nvp this year
will be
jokic
the nvp
should be giannis onto tecumbo
um how he has closed the season and i
know
uh
consistently it's been jokic for
and what he's had to deal with with two
key injuries to two major players
uh in jamal murray and porter jr
it will be jokic it should be honest him
getting his third mvp because how he's
been the last month and a half two
months
has been spectacular um i think he's
which is scary gone to a different level
but it should be honest
uh how long did it take you to shoot
your wendy's commercials oh man that was
it those were two day shoots and i hope
people enjoyed them
it was great because the director said
look we've seen the first two years were
great
but we're good
we're gonna let you and the actors just
ad live we have a script that we can
somewhat follow but here's the script
but do whatever you guys want and we did
whatever you want so what you see a lot
are a lot of first takes us just being
us and working off one another which
made it fun yeah but how tough was it
that you had to miss a shot on purpose
it was very difficult because that's not
my dna theodore
you know that's not my theodore that's
not my dna i had to look
and like brick i'm like are you sure you
want this like oh we're never going to
use it i look at the commercial they use
it people
i don't miss that bad no you don't i do
not miss that bad no you don't
no you don't
uh hey great to have you back and uh
good luck on the playoffs aren't the nba
playoffs going to be great look i didn't
even talk about brooklyn
like
simmons
now he's not going to even play in the
play
what is brooklyn and the lakers both in
playing situations only start of the
season they were picked to face one
another in the nba finals now they are
scratching and clawing just to make the
regular playoffs that this year is going
to be great the playoffs yeah the ben
simmons thing how did how did the nets
not know
that he
had an injury
i'm going to give
darryl morway and
philly a lot
[Laughter]
they must
pop that fishing reel they got they got
it well boy
yeah
i mean he needed he needed the last 10
games of the regular season to get ready
and
now i wonder you know kyrie's going to
be able to play unless they go to
toronto and all right like this harden
feels like a detriment to philadelphia
like it's just
it's this trade didn't turn out to be
what i think we thought it was going to
be
i think at the end of the day it will be
miami milwaukee in the east finals
and i think at the end of the day
it will be phoenix and memphis
in the west finals wow
though i mean if if steph can come back
and play like he played the first month
and a half
and draymond green
kind of picks up his game a little bit
because clay is starting to come on now
a little bit so if they can find that
chemistry which i don't know if they can
this late
um memphis is playing
out of their minds and i wouldn't mind
seeing a
dylan brooks john morant
guards versus
chris paul and devin booker i kind of
want to see that it'd be fun
have fun thursday night uh we'll talk to
you next week thanks for joining us
theodore love you glad to be back
layoff baby my darnettes love y'all
reggie aloysius miller junior iii we'll
come back we'll hear from tiger woods
right after this